this is the same argument as to why uh
polls why the american election is still
done on paper right
uh yeah you should do it on paper and
incidentally
i think the growth of postal voting is
completely unacceptable i'm with i'm
with
the donald there because when i was a
kid in the uk
you had postal voting but it was
basically confined to people serving
overseas in the military
it wasn't because i was on holiday right
or people who are bedridden
in other words you'd ask for a postal
vote in the most exceptional
circumstances
you know i can remember driving very old
people to
the polling station uh on polling day
uh in you know those actually this is
with my parents driving you know when i
was kind of 10 or something
they'd drive people who needed a lift to
the polling station right
now this business of a um
they're all sorts of things you can
register other people once you've done
that
if you help someone register to vote uh
if you're a member of a political party
uh you then enjoy something called
reciprocation bias which is
given that these people filled in the
paperwork for me i'd feel like a bit of
a [ __ ] not voting for them
there's the possibility of coercion
within households where the dad
or someone else basically gathers up all
the votes and votes collectively
okay uh there's the possibility simply
of non-privacy
that you could in a coercive
relationship demand to see how the other
person has voted
um and there's also the possibility of
fraud at scale
uh which let's face it the americans
don't don't have a perfect record of
that and that jfk didn't deserve to be
elected in 1959 i don't think
i mean that you know there was a whole
load of balance stuffing in chicago and
places
and um uh i i think that it's not
it's not merely essential for the
process to be honest it needs to be seen
to be honest
because the real point of uh the real
part of democracy is not
that you get a consensus on what
government you want it's that people
arrive a consensus around a sincere
belief about what everybody else wants
right you know it's not it's not a
simple matter of aggregating preferences
it's getting the effective consensus
of everybody that this is the collective
decision
writ launch and the second you start
having weird electronic things and the
second you start to have postal voting
i think that disappears and i i think
it's highly dangerous
and we're seeing that now right we're
seeing the fall out of that now yeah so
actually oddly although i totally i you
know i think the result is genuine i
think by
one i'm not necessarily i'm not
necessarily disputing that i think for
the longer term this practice of
widespread postal voting
um is getting a bit concerning i'd agree
also also you could argue that this is a
decision
okay which merits a walk
by maybe it's five minutes i'm not
saying it's three hours standing in a
queue and all that kind of [ __ ] goes on
where there's
you know effectively voter suppression
and that's gonna be clamped on as well
but this is a decision where i think it
just merits a walk
right to make it a bit serious okay
this isn't like voting for [ __ ] x
factor or
cake world or done skit
or whatever these flaming programs are
it's a bit more serious than that
and i think you should just get off your
ass put some clothes on
and go for a [ __ ] walk you want
something you want some rituals some
symbolism behind
it pilgrimage make a pilgrimage to the
voting booth just just say this is
slightly unusual
you know this isn't just and you know
they're i mean you know
um it's a really really important point
i think that um
uh that business of voting at home is
not really the same
because have you actually thought about
it i mean the point about the walk
and this is the slightly you know one
slight downside over zoom versus
business travel although i'm a huge zoom
advocate
is that when you travel to a meeting you
did have an hour to think about the
meeting while you're in transit
and sometimes now you find yourself
teleported into a meeting from a
different continent
with like one minute to prepare and so
you know i mean that's that's another
point i'd make which is i just think the
walk is good
again you know it says okay i'm going
here i'm making a tolerable degree of
effort
um you know i'm not just gonna basically
chicken
tick a box and get it over with and i
think it deserves that level of
solemnity
that's that's what i'd say